ozzie deserves congratulations do you
know this fact in 2009 ozzy got his
driver's license after 19 attempts 19
drivers test yes
i mean that's stone there was about two
or three okay
the door was open the car was parked
yeah but there was a note mr osborne you
failed and i suggest you don't try and
drive this vehicle any further
you can't show up high to your driving
test
[Laughter]
you're too funny you were nervous yeah
it makes sense i had to take a couple
just calm down yeah a couple of drinks
you passed that at a traffic light
during one of your tests
you know
if you would only just videotape all of
your driving tests it would be probably
the most successful turn those two okay
the guy didn't get in the [ __ ] car
with me
the driving the driving test guy has to
be in the car with you in order to pass
and he wouldn't get in the car with you
i guess you didn't take it that
seriously no no no so when you
eventually passed you showed up sober
yeah i mean that's what sobriety brought
me up [ __ ] driver's license yeah do
you drive around now you do yeah and
there's nobody not very far yeah i mean
i got my assistant tony goes i think i
think you're going to be close to the
wall
do you seem to know how to drive i mean
yeah i was driving illegally for years
you were but do you drive both in the
states and in
england so you can figure out the right
and the left every time you no
right and left is tough
even for the most experienced driver
but so you drove illegally for years you
were high as a kite and you know you
know so many people know the there's one
rule of driving everyone knows you're
not allowed to like be high and drive
right and to show up at the driving test
high that proves that you don't know
anything that might mean you're going to
flunk
if only you had passed that would have
been great i also love that you know how
ozzie had that voice recognition thing
in his car please say telephone on
select number or name i don't tell you i
don't i don't know
trouble with voice recognition i can't
imagine why the car couldn't understand
your voice nobody else [ __ ] goes
to the car exactly
you